in January 1941 the 28 year old French
writer Albert Camus began work on a
novel about a virus that spreads
uncontrollably from animals to humans
and ends up destroying half the
population of a representative modern
town it was called la peste the plague
eventually published in 1947 and
frequently described as the greatest
European novel of the second half of the
20th century the book written in sparse
haunting prose takes us through a
catastrophic outbreak of a disease in
the lightly fictionalized town of aha
on the algerian coast as seen through
the eyes of the novel's hero a doctor
here a version of Camus himself as the
novel opens an air of eerie normality
reigns aha is an ordinary town writes
camu nothing more than a French
Prefecture on the coast of Algeria the
inhabitants lead busy money centered and
denatured lives they barely noticed that
they are alive then with the pacing of a
thriller the horror begins dr. Theo
comes across a dead rat then another and
another soon the town is overrun with
the mysterious deaths of thousands of
rats who stumble out of their hiding
places in a daze let out a drop of blood
from their noses and expire the
inhabitants accused the authorities of
not acting fast enough so the rats are
removed in the town heaves a sigh of
relief both dr. Theo suspects that this
is not the end he has read enough about
the history of plagues and transmissions
from animals to humans to know that
something is afoot soon an epidemic
ceases aha
the disease transmitting itself from
citizen to citizens spreading panic and
horror in every street in order to write
the book Camus immersed himself in the
history of plagues he read books on the
black death that killed 50 million
people in Europe in the 14th century the
Italian plague of 1629 that killed 280
thousand people across northern Italy
the Great Plague of London of 1665 as
well as plagues that ravaged
cities on China's eastern seaboard
during the 18th and 19th centuries in
March 1942 Camus told the writer Andre
Malraux that he wanted to understand
what plague meant for Humanity said like
that it might sound strange he added but
this subject seems so natural to me
Camus was not writing about one plague
in particular nor was this narrowly as
has sometimes been suggested a
metaphoric tale about the recent Nazi
occupation of France Camus was drawn to
his theme because in his philosophy we
are all unbeknownst to us already living
through a plague that is a widespread
silent invisible disease that may kill
any of us at any time
and destroy the lives we assumed was
solid the actual historical incidents we
call plagues are merely concentrations
of a universal pre condition they are
dramatic instances of a perpetual rule
that we are vulnerable to being randomly
exterminated by a bacillus an accident
or the actions of our fellow humans our
exposure to plague is at the heart of
camis view that our lives are
fundamentally on the edge of what he
termed the absurd
proper recognition of this absurdity
should not lead us to despair pure and
simple
it should rightly understood be the
start of a redemptive tragicomic
perspective like the people of a Hall
before the plague we assume that we've
been granted immortality and with this
naivety come behaviors that camu
abhorred a hardness of heart an
obsession with status a refusal of joy
and gratitude a tendency to moralize and
judge the people of a heart associate
plagued with something backward that
belongs to another age they are in their
eyes modern people with phones trams
aeroplanes and newspapers they are
surely not going to die like the
wretches of 17th century London or 18th
century Canton it's impossible it should
be the plague everyone knows that has
vanished from the West says one
character yes everyone knew that can be
add sardonically except the dead
for Camus when it comes to dying there
is no progress in history there is no
escape from our frailty being alive
always was and will always remain an
emergency as one might put it truly an
inescapable underlying condition plague
or no plague there is always as it were
the plague if what we mean by this is a
susceptibility to sudden death an event
that can render our lives
instantaneously meaningless and yet in
the novel still the citizens deny their
fate even when a quarter of the city is
dying
they keep imagining reasons why the
problem won't happen to them the book
isn't attempting to panic us because
panic suggests a response to a dangerous
but short-term condition from which we
can eventually find safety but there can
never be safety and that is why for
Camus we need to love our fellow damned
humans and work without hope or despair
for the amelioration of suffering life
is a hospice never a hospital Camus
writes pestilence is so common there
have been as many plagues in the world
as there have been Wars yet plagues and
Wars always find people equally
unprepared when war breaks out people
will say it won't last
it's too stupid and war is certainly too
stupid but that doesn't prevent it from
lasting the citizens of a heart were
like the rest of the world they were
humanists they did not believe in
pestilence a pestilence does not have
human dimensions so people tell
themselves that it is unreal that it is
a bad dream which will end the people of
our town were no more guilty than anyone
else they merely forgot to be modest and
thought that everything was still
possible for them which implied that
pestilence was impossible and they
continued with business with making
arrangements for travel and holding
opinions why should they have thought
about the plague which negates the
future negates journeys and negates
debate they considered themselves free
and no one will ever be free as long as
there is plague or pestilence or famine
at the height of the plague when five
hundred people a week
one of CAM use particular enemies in the
novel steps into view a Catholic priest
called panel ooh he gives a sermon to
the city in the cathedral of the main
square and seeks to explain the plague
as God's punishment for depravity but
cam whose hero doctor who loathes this
approach the plague is not a punishment
for anything deserved that would be to
imagine that the universe was moral or
had some sort of design to it but doctor
vo watches a young innocent child die in
his hospital and he knows better
suffering is entirely randomly
distributed it makes no sense it is no
ethical force it is simply absurd and
that is about the kindest thing one can
say of it the doctor works tirelessly
against death he tries to lessen the
suffering of those around him but he is
no saint in one of the most central
lines of the book Camus writes this
whole thing is not about heroism it's
about decency
it may seem a ridiculous idea but the
only way to fight the plague is with
decency a character asks via what
decency might be and Doctor Who yours
response is as clipped as it is eloquent
in general I can't say remarks the
doctor but in my case I know that it
consists in doing my job despite the
horror Camus who in an earlier essay had
compared humanity to the wretched
character of Sisyphus but then asked us
to imagine Sisyphus happy maintains a
characteristically keen sense of what
makes life worth enduring his doctor who
appreciates dancing love and nature he
is hugely sensitive to the smell of
flowers to the colors at sunset and like
Camus adore swimming in the sea slipping
out after an evening on the wards to
surrender himself to the reassuring
immensity of the waves eventually after
more than a year the plague herbs away
the townspeople celebrate it is
apparently the end of suffering
normality can return but this is not how
come you sees it Doctor Who you may have
helped to defeat this particular
outbreak of the plague but he knows
there will always be
others in CHEM whose words via knew that
this Chronicle could not be a story of
definitive victory it could only be the
record of what had to be done and what
no doubt would have to be done again
against this terror as he listened to
the cries of joy that arose from the
town via recalled that this joy was
always under threat he knew that this
happy crowd was unaware of something
that one reads in books which is that
the plague bacillus never dies or
vanishes entirely that it remains
dormant for dozens of years that it
waits patiently in bedrooms cellars
trunks handkerchiefs and old papers and
that the day will come when the plague
will once again rouse its rats and send
them to die in some new well contented
City Camus speaks to us in our own times
not because he was a magical seer who
could intimate what the best scientists
could not but because he correctly sized
up human nature and knew about a
fundamental and absurd vulnerability in
us that we cannot usually bear to
remember in the words of one of his
characters Camus knew as we do not that
everyone has inside it himself this
plague because no one in the world no
one can ever be immune
if you're interested in trying
psychotherapy the School of Life offers
a service by Skype around the world
click on the link for further details
you